it is the foundation of all of our
freedoms there can be no other freedoms
any progress that has ever been made in
terms of the advancement of personal
liberty and social liberty has come
through the exercise of free speech
what is free speech is it the same as
being able to say anything without
repercussions
oh it depends what you mean by
repercussions so uh
if by repercussions you mean that the
state can arrest you
uh and lock you up or fine you or you
can be uh harassed
threatened intimidated uh pushed out of
your job then no those are not
acceptable repercussions in a liberal
society but if you mean by repercussions
criticism ridicule uh that kind of thing
in other words more speech in response
to your speech even protest in response
to your speech then
of course you have absolutely no right
because when people protest against your
form of speech that they're exercising
their own free speech that is absolutely
fine as well yeah i think it's
actually quite simple this point but
this is a point that is missed all the
time
it's really straightforward in in a in a
liberal system a liberal society this is
something
that has been completely overlooked
anyone should be able to say whatever
they want
uh and then people are able to say what
they want in turn
in response and that's how that's how it
should work so when you hear
um particularly writers for the guardian
talking about how
the thing is when people talk about free
speech what they really mean is they
want consequence free speech
first no one has ever said that i mean
literally no one has ever
so this is an incredible it's not even
so much of a straw man it's too
insubstantial even to be made of straw
there's literally nobody who comes close
to the invisible man yeah
it's invisible man like no no one has
ever said that
that they want the right to say whatever
they want without someone criticizing
them back no one's ever said that
and if they have then they're deranged
and they're they're we're talking about
a fringe group of people
so that has to be put to rest that that
that over
lie um so no free free speech is the
right to say whatever you want and for
people to say whatever they want back to
you
why does it matter because it is the
bedrock of a liberal democracy it is the
it is the it is the foundation of all of
our freedoms
there can be no other freedoms any any
progress that has ever been made in
terms of the advancement of personal
liberty and social liberty
has come through the exercise of free
speech of saying what you want
expressing your thoughts
it is the route to personal autonomy if
you can't uh
express what you what you feel about
something then you cannot develop
we cannot innovate without free speech
there can be no innovation there has
never been an innovation without
without the freedom to say what you want
and particularly to say controversial
things that's how innovation happens
you can't reason without speech because
uh the very active reason
is typically a collaborative effort the
the way that we evolve and learn
is through uh uh discussion with other
people and expressing ideas and getting
it wrong and making mistakes and all of
that is part of it
um so it is the linchpin of absolutely
everything that we value if we value
freedom and that's why it is
it is alarming to me that people are so
cavalier about it when you hear a lot of
people online
when they want free speech skeptics i
call them you know when they when they
call it freeze peach
you know that really original pun and
they sometimes have an image of a peach
frozen in an ice cube they say oh look
at you with your freeze peach
for start it's the most unimaginative i
mean you know they should be banned
just for criminal and originality right
but they they they say this stuff
um but to be so cavalier about such a
foundational
principle is actually pretty damn
disturbing it's like they don't care and
they don't realize
that they're they are themselves
dependent on
on the on their right to free speech in
order to behave like [ __ ] they they
need to have that right too
um so you know people shouldn't be so
clear about it doesn't free speech allow
those [ __ ] to cause harm and
offense though
and other [ __ ] as well yeah that's
the point they can i'm not here
suggesting again
this would be the interpretation oh
you've just mocked people who use the
phrase freeze peach uh and therefore
you're trying to shut them down aren't
you trying to silence them you're trying
to sense them no
criticism is not the same as censorship
i i often think that people who mistake
the two must be doing so willfully they
have to be i mean how else could they
you know everyone knows this um so i
often get that as well like if i've when
i've mocked things in the past
um people have said to me why are you
having to go there i thought you
i thought you cared about free speech i
always get this all the time it's like
yeah
i'm exercising my free speech to
criticize what they said
that's kind of how it works and they can
do it back to me that's fine it's okay
i i think one of the reasons i wrote the
book is fundamentally
there are so many misconceptions around
around free speech that
uh so many basic misconceptions you know
that really people should have learned
about
a long time ago and and you're always
having to fend them off
and i'd just like to put those things to
rest and i think i think people
need to have uh a a a sort of more
sensible conception of what is meant
by the concept of free speech and so
most of the arguments around this topic
are dealing with straw men and
they're dealing with misconceptions and
so if you can just get beyond all that
detritus then we can have a discussion
about the actual issues because there
are some very difficult issues
surrounding the topic
but we're not going to get anywhere if
people don't know what free speech means
so that's one of the reasons i wanted to
i i learned
about ethics and meta ethics from a
buddy who's at
oxford uni and i'd never learned this
before and what you told me was that
if you have two people trying to debate
ethics who
disagree on meta ethics the ethical
discussion actually breaks down because
the underlying principles that they're
coming to the table holding
don't support any sort of discussion on
top of that and it seems like
you're trying to sort of do this here
like look this is the battleground that
we're supposedly playing on
yeah we can now have a conversation any
kind of either productive or
unproductive but at least we can have a
conversation
because we know the rules of the game
it's exactly right
and actually i've been wrestling with
this issue for a while now is is how do
you
argue against those who are incapable of
argument
this is really hard because i'm all for
i think we need more discussion not less
i think we
mean i think one of the major problems
that i think i've said it to you before
one of the major problems that we face
at the moment people aren't talking to
each other people from opposing
political ideas
they're not they're not sitting down and
talking to each other so i'm all for
doing that and i will always do that but
if someone comes into the room and wants
to talk but they're not going to use
play by the rules right
in other words they're going to just
throw insults in other words they're
going to start guessing what they think
you believe
right which is something they always do
uh they're going to misrepresent your
perspective in other words they're just
arguing with a version of themselves
that they've created uh if they're going
to do that
then that's that's bad faith you can't
you can't actually argue with someone
like that and i think
i think it's really important when it
comes to argument
uh that yes you make an effort you may
go out your way to talk to people who
disagree with you
but if they are unwilling or incapable
of argumentation
then don't bother and block them i
seriously mean i think i think and you
might say well you're creating an echo
chamber well look
someone comes in and says there are 32
letters in the alphabet
let's debate well i'm not going to
debate that person because
you know it's clearly not the case and
if they absolutely refuse to accept the
basic premise
you can't go you just can't go any
further than that i had this the other
day where someone on twitter was on me
saying um
nobody oh you're saying everyone in this
country just accepts that uh
or just uses they all the time as a
singular pronoun
right we'd already passed the point of
you know where you do if you don't know
this the gender of the
person and that's something that's a
colloquial form of the term they
but the idea that vast majority people
do not understand they as a plural
pronoun
is simply not true and the only way you
would think that that is the case is if
you don't know people
or if you're being willfully obtuse in
order to to to win the argument so
therefore i'm not going to debate that
person
you have to accept certain premises in
order to to move on
one of them is just knowing how to argue
why is it mostly people on the right
who seem to be promoting freedom of
speech like we rarely hear
the left complain about lacking free
speech
well the opposite was true when i was a
child so
this is this is something that i think
shows us that it's not a part of that
issue you know
when i was a kid there used to be i mean
you're too young but there were things
like
uh the daily mail and the daily express
i think
tried to had a campaign to try and ban
david cronenberg's film
crash uh there were um all sorts of
campaigns every now and then whenever
there was i mean
it go back even before my time there
were campaigns against things like the
last temptation of christ the scorsese
film
or las tango in paris um so there's
always these sort of
centaurus kind of campaigns going on and
say that we should ban artistic
expression of one form or another
but it was always coming from the right
when i was a kid it was always i mean
you just associated i mean then if you
think of mary whitehouse who was the
famous campaigner
who did the cleanup tv campaign back in
the uh the 60s and 70s and then
the video nasties campaign in the 80s
you know in the 80s they banned films
like driller killer
and um evil dead was banned you know the
sam raimi film
uh that was that was banned by the uh by
the video nasties
uh scandal uh and all of this was coming
from the right this was just the way
that because because conservatives
traditionally have a sort of
i suppose a kind of old-fashioned view
of decorum and that kind of thing
and they and but they all bought into
this myth
uh which was very much mary whitehouse's
thing that uh popular entertainment has
the capacity to corrupt the masses
and it was it was a kind of very
snobbish idea that basically suggested
that poor people
were like robots who just do what they
you know they just see stuff and they
react okay
um that exact philosophy and idea is now
predominantly expressed by those on the
left it's a weird
shift it's difficult to determine when
exactly it happened but you'll notice
that all
all calls for sort of artistic
censorship or criticism which is saying
well why hasn't this film uh got more
diversity or representational why
why is why is this film sending a
negative message about women or a
negative message about
about gay people or whatever it might be
and when of course the role of art
it has absolutely nothing to do with
messages or morality uh necessarily not
not that
art can't have a moral message if it
wants to but i it always puts me off
when it does i find it quite
reverberative
as a form but you know um this is now
coming
always from the guardian always from the
new states but always from the leftist
publication this is just where it is now
um this very haughty puritanical
approach uh these
this pearl clutching would be the the
phrase
it's a very good phrase is it because
you really imagine people go oh you know
you know very camp very kind of oh this
person sets up this rude
disgusting thing um it's just shifted
and it'll no doubt shift back again you
know uh every now and then you get it
from the right
even now you do you get it when when
when certain uh creative people do
something that is considered offensive
and you'll get that and that will always
happen it's just
it's just a strange phenomenon that at
the moment uh
the the ones who would seek to shut down
forms of expression
tend to be on the left and of course
that is largely down to the new social
justice movement which mistrusts
at its heart mistrusts speech and sees
speech as violence
and conflates the two things uh and
pretty much everyone within that
camp i mean there are there are
disagreements along the way but
pretty much everyone is of the view that
language has the capacity to
normalize behavior and and that people
do follow these mechanical cues from
these mechanical linguistic cues um and
ultimately that's down to a mistrust of
humanity and particularly a mistrust of
working-class people that's what you'll
find which is why they often go after
working-class comics
uh because it's the audiences that are
dangerous they won't go after a
middle-class comic
talking about various things because you
know they're better educated audience
they understand what they do you know
it's
there is a deep snap very patronizing
isn't it this sort of odd incredible
paternalistic like kind of overbearing
like nani like neo-nanny state
in a really bizarre way there was an
article
uh when the dapper laughs you remember
the last controversy yeah yeah
we're still around i have absolutely no
idea but
they succeeded in having his tv show
booted off i think was itv too
um and there was a really alarmist
ludicrous article online talking about
how
his show was a rapist almanac they used
i don't think they used that word right
correctly but it was absolutely insane
and um
actually the whole article was hilarious
because he'd obviously gone through his
thesaurus and just tried to sound as
learned as possible but actually by
doing so came across as incredibly
unlettered
um but but when he um wrote this article
and people but it wasn't just that he
wrote i mean you can have some maniacs
writing articles about this sort of
stuff but
so many people bought into it and even
comedians i know
signed this open letter saying we should
have this band it was a it was a weird
moment although
i have to say some of those who i know
who did that now
uh regret it um but of course the it was
really because dapa last audience were
working class
and this idea that they would watch him
picking up girls and being
being a cheeky lad or whatever i mean
look it's not to my taste i don't i
don't even know what it was right i
watched a bit of it and i thought
it's not for me you know but but i don't
think for a second
that some uh working-class guys are
going to watch it and think all right
i've got permission now to go out and
commit some sexual assault
incredible incredible this this it is
just patronizing isn't it
it is just a fear of of of people who
aren't like you
it's it's because believe it or not it
doesn't matter what class you come from
everyone knows the difference between a
joke and real life
and even if it were an outright
instruction to behave badly
people don't people do have agency they
do make decisions you know
they don't just do things because
someone tells them but this is a belief
that you can't
actually we can't get over because it's
so ingrained now it's everywhere you
know it comes down to even
in parliament when boris johnson was
using the metaphor of the surrender bill
and you had all these labour mps saying
that your language is normalizing
violence
people are going to hear you using
military metaphors well politic
political language is full of military
metaphors
conflict we we go on to fight we need
strength all of this sort of stuff but
it's interpreted as
incitement right well again this is
based on a very patronizing view
of of humanity it's not true did you see
miley cyrus drop herself in it with her
preference remarks showing
underlying transphobia
i didn't why don't you fill me in on
that one i'm not up on my miley cyrus
well
let me tell you this is in out.com
by may rude i'm not sure if that's a
real name so this is
this is the gay press is out.com
well it sounds a bit gay that's only you
can say that
uh miley cyrus is making waves with new
comments about her sexuality
in a new interview she not only says
that she prefers women to men but also
attempts to explain why
girls are way hotter we know this the 28
year old bisexual said in an interview
with sirius xm's bar stool radio
everyone i think can agree that from
ancient times dicks make wonderful
sculptures
other than that i'm not as interested i
like dicks as p
art pieces and sculptural i love the
shape i think it looks really good on a
table
the singer continued it's good if i can
just get it in and go away
because i don't want it eyeing me up
that's how i truly feel i really feel
good about saying that
she dug in even deeper adding everyone
knows that tits are prettier than balls
that's what ended up making female
relationships make more sense to me and
then this
cuts back to maerud i wish that i could
say this news makes me excited and proud
to be a woman and a lesbian but cyrus's
quote is littered with transphobia
this kind of gender essentialism was
left behind by most of the queer
community years ago
genitals do not equal gender and miley
should know this and then it just keeps
on going in an age where turks are more
vocal than ever
people like miley believe that genitals
determine gender trans women and girls
are often considered to be in public
spaces trans women should be kicked blah
blah blah this isn't the first time
she's gotten in hot water
she seemed to imply that being gay is a
choice i don't think that mighty meant
to traffic in turf talking points but
the fact is she did
and should know better the stakes are
too high for someone with as big of a
spotlight on her as accidentally
spreading this sort of rhetoric
miley i love you but i'm going to need
you to make this right
and i'm sure that miley cyrus really
took that to heart
i'm sure the incredible entitlement of
that kind of article is
is insufferable isn't it and it's um uh
not only actually did i read that
i i tweeted about it so when i said i
hadn't heard of it because i it's
because i read this stuff every day
that that it could have been anyone
talking about anything
i mean the idea that if you find breasts
more attractive than
a scrotum uh that is a turf
viewpoint you know that phrase is just
ludicrous anyway turf
um that it is in some way transphobic
uh you you see this all the time general
genital preferences are are transphobic
no they're not
they're obviously not but i shouldn't
have to say it's obviously not the case
uh that is true i mean and also the idea
listen to what she said in the article
the queer community left this behind
years ago
most gay people have genital preferences
sorry to break this to you
the vast majority you've clearly never
been on a cruising ground i tell you
what
because it's it is very very much about
the genitals and don't you tell me
that suddenly people are blind they're
blind to what what is in the
what is in the underwear department they
don't care are you kidding don't
grind it that's all that's all they care
about
pretty much yeah i mean the um the funny
the funny thing that i saw there was it
was like the we talked about grievance
hierarchies right it was like the
hierarchy
of different things that she'd done so i
kind of had it in my head i could
imagine this kind of like quite
haughty um foreman working
like looking over a building site and
he's like looking he goes uh
feminism women yeah check lesbian yep
women
check oh we're looking good here oh oh
you haven't you haven't quite got it
right you didn't quite get it right on
the transphobia did you i'm gonna have
to
i'll give you i'll give you a b minus
and uh you can hand this in at reception
and we'll see if we can get you back
next week
yeah i mean like is it some sort of
calling card
i mean for one thing like it's such a
shame we even have to discuss like the
article sounds banal doesn't it it
sounds
why do i care what what miley cyrus
thinks about tits
i don't care about that it's so it's
really not interesting i've
i can pretty much guarantee i've got no
interest in anything she's got to say
but that is
that really uh that really takes a bit
so why am i even having to talk about
this well it's because
journalists uh are picking through
sifting through everything that people
say
and trying to find some way to turn it
into an offensive comment how boring
what a boring
existence this person must have and did
you see
jordan peterson's interview with decker
aiken head from the times and then the
subsequent write-up
yeah what were you thoughts on yeah i
didn't see it all to be fair i saw
i saw mikayla's um response to
it and um i mean it was quite of
i mean but the the snapshots i heard
because i heard some of the recording
and i could tell that this was a hit
piece even even before reading the
the final i could tell that the the
there was there was something about the
smugness of the tone and the kind of
combative nature of the interview that
you knew that this person had already
decided in advance what they thought
about this situation they were going to
say what they thought about it and then
having read uh what
what actually happened uh yeah i mean
it's it's it's a hit piece that's what
it is it's it's someone who is not going
in in good faith
and i think it's it's the wrong way to
go about an interview if you're going if
you if you're serious about
being an interviewer you need to sort of
coax out some truths about that person
or
get them to reveal some things about
themselves not use it as an opportunity
to smear someone and particularly with
someone like jordan peterson who let's
face it
has probably been mischaracterized more
than anyone else except for perhaps
jk rowling uh the two of them uh are
right up there as
people who've you know when you see the
level of vitriol
against them and the accusations that
are thrown against them
you know particularly with jordan
peterson who is someone who isn't even
really that political um
all of this stuff is weird because you
read it it bears no resemblance to
reality and this is what i'm talking
about
when they say about arguing people who
are capable of argumentation someone who
is willing to just completely
mischaracterize
and not provide evidence for their
mischaracterizations you can't
talk to that person it's like talk to a
madman there's no point in debating
someone who's who's literally in in
living in their own reverie
their own vision of what the world they
would like the world to be and that's
unfortunately where you are with someone
like that i've been in discussions
with people online about jk rowling
talking about all the transphobic things
she said
and whenever i said can you quote me
something transphobic she said
they never can i mean the fact that they
never look at jordan peterson
same thing same thing right exactly
precisely the same thing
well in in a sense it's worse because uh
you have
you have most of his old lectures are
online so you have a
a a verifiable record of a man whose
opposition to tyranny in all its forms
including nazism
could not be better documented so the
idea that then you can then say
oh he's supportive of nazis it's it's
it's so
it's not even something you can debate
because it is just so fundamentally the
opposite of the truth
there's no point in getting involved in
that you know so it is infuriating but
that's the point which you have to say
no well i'm stepping back from this
conversation this isn't someone
this the the problem is that so many of
these people who are living in this
hallucin
hallucination of of a society of a world
are pretty prominent commentators uh and
interviewers for various major
newspapers so
it's it's it's it's frustrating because
you have to
i suppose what i'm saying in short is
the adults just need to start talking to
each other and let the kids
you know have their little tantrums and
let them get on with it but the adults
need to talk to each other i mean you
think
with someone like decker aikenhead who's
like lead invest
interview reporter or whatever for the
times you think that she would have been
one of the adults
i don't know much to be fair i don't
know much about her
but i think i'm perfectly prepared to
concede because of my lack of knowledge
of her work that she is actually a very
sensible
intelligent journalist and on this
occasion she allowed her passion to
overwhelm her reason
uh i mean that is a conflict that that
lives in the heart of all of us um
and we're all likely to to fall prey to
it if if we have a
a particular bug bear about something or
if we are uh
if we have i mean all of us at any given
time have full false perceptions of the
world the key is
never to lose society of your
objectivity and i think
uh but it but but it is undoubted
undoubtedly the case that in that
particular interview
uh she didn't behave in a professional
way and let herself down and the result
was a poor piece of journalism
well i mean is the interesting thing now
talking about freedom of speech not that
she is permitted
to write that swath
of unrepresentative maligned
um very preconceived ideas
about a man who 15 minutes into the
interview has to take a break to go and
cry
in 15 minutes in breaks down talking
about how
other people have been positively
affected by his work
and the only reason that we're even
given any notion of that
is that michaela had the foresight to
actually record the call
so that they can then put it up to to
see do you know what i mean yeah
didn't she say something in the
interview about how he's not in touch
with his emotions he doesn't have any
emotion there was something in there
relating to it was it was yeah it was it
was obviously
well that's the thing about peterson in
particular as well he's obviously not a
confrontational combative person
no right he really isn't and this this
um view of him as someone who's
who's in it for the fight and gets
stopped gets off on
on the fight is is is probably not true
i know who knows it's not true look at
what he's saying
during the very very first set he breaks
the fourth wall he obviously thinks at
least stepping in
that this decker lady is
on side in one form or another and i'm
gonna guess that having been through the
sort of hell of all of the rehab and the
trips around the world and all that
stuff that he's had to do
they'll have filtered this very very
very carefully to think right are we
going to be okay is this the sort of
thing that dad's up to it's obviously
going to be worthwhile it's the times
it's reputable it's blah blah blah he's
got the new book coming out
and he breaks the fourth wall early on
in that and says um
i've every time that i have one of these
combative interviews
um i have to take a rest afterwards
almost i feel sort of physically drained
once it happens
so he's saying to her look like i know
that you're sort of not a part of that
and then slowly over time obviously that
hope just gets chipped away yeah man i
mean like michaela's a good mate and
i i really feel like that family just
like if anyone's had enough like really
i know
after the last year the problem is that
that because so much of
of i hate thinking in terms of sides but
i think
i just see so much evidence of of those
who are
you know completely enamored of this
social justice ideology
they're very quick to dehumanize people
they're very quick to demonize i mean
that they to the extent that they don't
care if people die and will gloat
if someone dies who doesn't agree with
them and that that
that to me is an inhuman way you've lost
your humanity what as soon as you start
doing that
you're not really a human being in any
serious sense in terms of your
uh emotional capacity you're you're like
you you've made yourself
you've made yourself ironically into the
the sort of a version of the person
you're projecting
um onto these other people and and
that is very sad and i think the the
[ __ ] cruelty
of someone who can see someone who's
obviously been through serious medical
problems
and yet you want to kick them when
they're down is uh uh
it is actually unfathomable to me i
don't i i can't imagine
i can't imagine ever getting myself into
this sort of place ever
ever where that would be the sort of
thing man like that type of journalism
that sort of like
very i don't know like if you if if
piers morgan lost
50 iq points and was 20 years ago like
that's the sort of
that still kind of like playing the heel
but with absolutely no
charm to it with no sort of good will
that's the sort of person i don't know
what decker aiken head looks like but i
imagine that it's kind of like a younger
piers morgan with a wig
and like a little bit more frumpy i
don't know what she looks like i i
thought she was older though i thought
she was more established um
i i don't know to be fair but um
i suppose what what i think it is is
yeah i mean it it depresses me when i
think about the way in which people
allow themselves to become these
monsters which is what you know
unless you have empathy empathy's got to
be the bottom line unless you unless you
and i think because identity politics
has become so tied to identity now
that it means that if someone is uh
challenging a world view instead of
welcoming that i mean you should you
should welcome it
and instead of welcoming it you you see
that person as a kind of
as someone who is the embodiment of evil
someone who is therefore
threatening uh your your identity who
you are
and and committing violence simply by
disagreeing with you
then it's very easy to to to get
yourself in a situation where you can
you can see that person is less than
human
and expendable and uh and that is really
at the heart of cancer culture isn't it
this idea that we
you know if we could just get rid of
these people who think differently than
us because
well something that peterson himself
talks about is the way in which when you
are challenged it feels painful
it's a kind of uh if you have to change
your mind and you get this shock of
awakening and you have it's a difficult
process
to be open-minded to be a free thinker
to challenge yourself and be challenged
by others all of that is really
difficult
um but rather than accept that actually
this is a positive form of growth
you know that that kind of those mini
form of destructions are a positive
thing for yourself as an individual is
to get rid of and eliminate
any possibility that it could happen
it's tied up with the whole idea of the
safe space culture the idea of
not being challenged and not being um
exposed to ideas that might make you
uncomfortable what they mean by
uncomfortable is challenge you
make you a better person make you a more
interesting and well-rounded person
we have to in a sense start from scratch
all of this stuff has to you know
it means the universities schools
everything's got to basically start from
scratch again
um because at the moment we are in this
inc you know this wilderness of tigers
where
and where there's no sensible
discussions going on everyone's out to
hurt each other
no one's wanting to listen uh they're
just having their own individual
scraps with imaginary enemies
it can't go on forever does cancel
culture exist
it it's incredible to me that anyone
would deny that it exists when the
evidence is so overwhelming
for it um i've i've been in
conversations with people about this
online and
there's a couple of threads online which
have hundreds and hundreds of examples
of
of people who've lost their jobs uh out
of um for something they've said at work
or something that's
uh you know of course it exists i mean
quite obviously i think you you know the
the main complaint of saying well no
one's been cancelled
again that's someone taking a metaphor
literally no one's saying that anyone is
literally being canceled council culture
is a shorthand
metaphor for a a form a method whereby
when you hear something that offends you
upsets you typically something quite
innocuous or relatively inconsequential
in other words part of cancer culture is
an
overreaction right so so you go in all
guns blazing and you don't stop until
that person has lost everything their
livelihood their job their reputation
absolutely it's all got to go because
there can be no redemption there can be
no forgiveness
and this happens again and again and the
examples of it are so
numerous that it is impossible to deny
with a straight face that it doesn't
exist and yet people do
you know it's for this it's the same
reason i mean you know people
hate to say it again but writers for the
guardian will continually say
cancer culture doesn't exist because
they are its chief practitioners you
know remember this is a publication
that when suzanne moore wrote that
article which they all disliked most of
the staff wrote a letter of complaint to
try and get her booted out
and then it's the same people who will
say that cancer culture doesn't exist
well let's well this is hardly
surprising
because the culture war is largely
engineered and motored by people like
the people who work at the guardian it's
their culture war this is the
identitarian left's culture war
but they are the same people will say
the culture war is a right-wing myth
but they're they're the antagonists it's
it's nuts but
jk rowling's said loads of stuff she
hasn't been cancelled why is she not
being cancelled
well you know the answer to that chris
let's she's a billionaire
and uh as we all know council culture
overwhelmingly affects poor people
and this is the other major myth about
it you know if you're a celebrity person
in the public guy who is financially
secure
uh it's very difficult to cancel you
know you can't cancel get jk rowling
she's the richest richest author in the
world
you can however cancel jillian phillip
who's the scottish author
who tweeted in support of jk rowling he
says she lost her publisher
and she lost her age that can happen uh
because she's she's expendable
you can't no publisher in their right
mind would get rid of jk rowling so no
she cannot be cancelled
but that does not justify that the the
venomous misogynistic abuse she gets on
a daily basis i mean that's still
on a human level just morally
unforgivable
however she she isn't subject to cancer
culture i will accept i will accept that
and um
the ones who are subject to cancer
culture are normally people who don't
have the means to stick up for
themselves who don't have the financial
resources to do so
who are intimidated because they're
going to work and suddenly they're
facing a tribunal because someone
overheard something they said
and and misinterpreted misinterpreted it
this isn't about
someone who's gone into work and starts
shouting about [ __ ] and puffs and and
and
how they should all be killed and stuff
that's the way it's portrayed no it's
someone who
made a joke that someone's
misinterpreted as being homophobic
because it hurt their feelings
and so they went and that you know it's
a different thing and it may not even
have been about gay people at all right
it's the the key
aspects of cancer culture is that the
slight is actually often
very small right and also it's it's
possible i mean there's um
a lot of people now talking about how we
should we should not have call out
culture we should have call in culture
and actually it sounds a bit tacky but
there's something in there in so far as
if you're in
the workplace and someone says something
that upsets you or offends you you call
in you go over to them and say
look what you said bothered me a bit can
we ever talk about it and you and you
resolve your things that way calling out
would be
screenshot the email put it online
let everyone know that this person is
evil and should be fired and hounded
and that's quite a good distinction to
make because that's what we used to do i
mean i've had disputes at work you know
i used to be a teacher i used to work in
a call center
i've had disputes with people uh and
i've took them to one side and said can
we discuss this and sometimes
i've been writing sometimes but you get
you reach a resolution because we're
human beings we can deal with conflict
and there's no such thing as a human
relationship that doesn't that is devoid
of conflict
um but if if my initial reaction was
always i want to see that person
fall i want to publicly shame that
person i want
to suffer that's not that's not justice
that's revenge
and i think that that's what that's what
is at the heart of this and then what we
mean by cancer culture
is this general propensity to seek
vengeance
for a perceived slight that may or may
not have been a slight in the first
place it may have been just you the way
that you perceived it
that's what cancer culture is and it
happens all the time so we need to again
go back to what i said start from
scratch the idea things we shouldn't
accept
uh that the culture war is a right-wing
myth uh that cancer culture does not
exist
uh that anyone is calling for uh free
speech without any kind of consequences
or criticism
none of those things are at all true and
yet they are stated as though they are
true and this comes back to a very
important problem that we face and they
gave us a word for it didn't they the
word is gaslighting
that so many people on the identitarian
left love to gaslight they would love
they will happily say to you
this is a thing that is happening when
it is not happening or this is the thing
that's not happening
when it plainly is happening they would
just deny observable
observable reality uh and they will keep
denying of the observable reality
so that you start to doubt your own
sanity that's what gas lighting means
comes from the film gaslight you know
where
the guy is constantly lowering the
lights and his wife saying why is it
getting so dim in here and he's saying
it's not
it's just you you know so that's what
that's what they do
and yet again they accuse others of
gaslighting
because that's what they do how far do
you think we are from thoughts being a
crime like is there
a significant philosophical or symbolic
difference
between thinking a thing in your head
and making the noises
of that thing with your mouth well
everyone should uh has a responsibility
to
think carefully about the things they
say and they they should do we have to
think carefully about the things we
think
no you can't uh nobody can afford to
express their
every unfiltered view that's why we have
a we have a filter
you know we i mean how could that be
our minds are very complex things we we
are
continually wrestling with difficult
ideas and everyone has thoughts that
they would not express
um but that's that's the point of
socialization that's why children
sometimes say the most
awful things you know hilarious things
yeah they just come out with it and they
say sometimes really
offensive and upsetting things because
they don't have that filter and they
don't have that sense of social
responsibility that's something that we
learn when we're socialized
um the idea of criminalizing someone's
thoughts
i mean of course it's uh horrific and
it's the stuff of dystopia that's why
dystopian writers such as philip k dick
always wrote about that kind of thing
whether it's actually happening is that
your question whether how far away from
it is
just so the interesting thing that i've
found
is that certain groups of people would
sooner have a lying ally than a truthful
opponent
so they would rather someone make the
mouth noises that they don't believe
and essentially be unreliable like they
don't know what that person's gonna do
that evidently not being themselves or
even if they don't they're perhaps
making themselves
willfully ignorant of their deception
yeah yeah rather than someone who
maybe isn't an actual opponent maybe
they're just slightly adjacent to them
or maybe they're not fully on board
but is being holy themselves and is
being completely truthful
and that to me i find that fascinating
how somebody i think
prepared to take deception as long as
it's deception on my side
oh well i think though the view that
deception is preferable to the truth
i mean there's this thing that they call
preference falsification is when you
you say what you think is the uh the the
most popular view not what you actually
think
the thing that you're meant to say
that's the phrase
it was it was coined by an economist and
i i'm
gutted i can't remember his name but you
can look it up preference falsification
it's very important
um because i remember talking to someone
who had been on question time and they
oh wait oh no misremembering someone who
knew someone had been on a question time
panel
and they said that they'd had this
discussion with all the politicians of
the journalists and then afterwards in
the green room
they'd all sort of said did you really
think that no i don't think and they all
agreed that they actually thought the
opposite
um but they knew that they had to give
the the that to say
sort that's a fairly standard thing in
politics i mean you know
politicians are always having to to tow
a certain party line the the problem is
that now
like you say um we there are all things
that we're expected to say even if we
don't believe them and i would urge
everyone never to say something you
don't believe i think i think
it's self-destructive to speak knowing
falsehoods is
is really self-destructive not only that
it means you don't know anyone people
don't know each other i would rather
know
what people actually think but i think
the reason why
particularly the social justice left
would rather they were lived in a world
of liars
firstly i think it's because a lot of
them are liars themselves and they they
are willing to be
like they're in good company well i
guess it's just a kind of sense of
the means always justify the ends i
think that's really what it what it's
about
um but also i think additionally to that
it's about this idea
that that it's about their belief that
language creates reality it's that
post-modern belief or
that everything that happens in the
world is down to the words that are
expressed
um and as a result of that if you have
opinions that are
uh shall we say objectionable uh and
those opinions are articulated
then they're out they've escaped like a
like a poison from a lab
you know they're like like like a virus
and therefore what happens is that
changes society
and poisons and infects society and i
think they genuinely believe that
as opposed to the truth of it which is
the opposite of that which is that if
you hear
objectionable ideas out loud you are
able to engage with them
and explain why they are wrong or expose
the people who are expressing it
all the other things that which is how
progress works
it's why we got over slavery in the 19th
century
through discussion and debate and people
wrangling with these
they're very difficult issues but issues
now
that everyone there's a complete
consensus on right you don't reach that
consensus
without discussion when when i hear of
um people attempting to criminalize
particularly with the trans debate
trying to attempt to criminalize the
language that people use
misgendering that kind of thing or
compelling speech as canada is now doing
when i hear that i think you have
learned nothing from civil rights
movements
you've learned nothing the the gay
rights movement never did this
they never suggested we should
criminalize people who who used
words about gay people in a certain way
or didn't accept uh gay equality
we never had that we had debate protest
and we had
uh we even had ridicule and we had
discussion and and persuasion
above all we had persuasion uh and it
worked now
you won't find many people who are
against equal rights for gay people
the ones the residual elements are tend
to be very religious
uh in fact so again you reach it you
reach
progress is achieved through open
discussion and
uh progress is stymied uh when people
misrepresent their own thoughts
uh for fear of uh the tyranny of the
collective of the of
of um the the the you know this what you
call peer pressure
where does the n word fit into free
speech recently we've had this
67 year old new york times writer donald
mcneil
fired for referring to the n-word isn't
it weird that if he was a rapper and
he'd said that would have been fine
what was the context of that that he was
quoting i believe there was a recent
example
just referring to something else yeah so
i guess he's one level removed from
saying it
yeah i think the truth is we all
acknowledge that when i say that words
and violence are two different things
i'm not saying that words don't have
power
or indeed that words don't have baggage
and when you have a word that is so
associated with uh the evils of of of
slavery
and a certainly a word that is favored
by racists
there's no getting around that um then
obviously
this is what i say about you know people
should think before they speak because
they should think not just about what
they are saying but
but but how how it is received that's
why clarity
is always important um so
having acknowledged that then you have
to talk about the intention of why the
word is being uttered
if you're quoting from a text if you're
teaching of mice and men
by steinbeck in which the word occurs
frequently if you're teaching
huckleberry finn although of course a
lot of people aren't now because they
they say it's a racist book because it
contains the word well context is
absolutely everything
um you couldn't the book let's take mark
twain
let's take the huckleberry thing right
the book wouldn't work if that word was
not there
because the work is a satire against
it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a book
which is pro
racial equality it is against those
people those hypocrites
because you'll notice that the
hypocrites in that novel are the adults
who believe that they are christian
and good and righteous and yet they
endorse slavery and it takes a child
to see through the evil of slavery right
that's the point and and that doesn't
work if you sanitize the reality of what
life was like
for someone like jim for a character
like jim right it doesn't work
so to say that the book is racist simply
because of the presence of a word that
many people find offensive
is to completely divorce firstly it's a
complete misinterpretation of what the
text is about
but it's also to empower a certain word
with this uh
undue weight and say that the word in of
itself is an evil word well that's
that's almost talismanic that's almost
that's what that almost invested with
the kind of significance
words are all about intent because
they're they're how we express our ideas
about the world
that that isn't i think we should be
very wary
of an overreaction however having said
that
and and for all my urging people to to
speak with karen to not go out of their
way to hurt other people's feelings
if if you've decided that you want to
use the word for whatever reason
that's up to you it is not for me if i
heard that someone
someone using that word or any kind of
racial slur authentically
from a place of racial hatred then
i would know that's not the sort of
person i want to associate with and i
will remove myself in that situation
pretty quickly or i will say something
you know if i feel like if i feel i'm
not gonna get beat into a pulp i would
probably say something to that person
i would complain um but if it's someone
in a classroom quoting a poem or didn't
it happen when someone was quoting james
baldwin
an academic best the best example i've
heard was a teacher
teaching chinese to americans
and there is a word in chinese that
sounds like the n-word
right he's trying he's trying to teach
them it phonetically it sounds like that
i think it's maybe
like cg or two c's instead
um but it's close enough um
also i mean even just the fact that
i get it that that word is loaded with
baggage and i have nightmares about
accidentally saying it sometimes on a
live stream or something not that
it's a word that i don't think i can't
remember using
because i'm so terrified that if it gets
into my lexicon somehow
that it might just sneak out at a really
in opportunity
no but that's the thing that's the other
really fascinating thing that if you're
a rapper
of any any racial descent
you can say it if you're a rapper you're
allowed
to say that word as many times as you
want if you're cardi b
it can be the majority of one of your
songs yeah but again there's context to
that there's context to the the genre
but there was no context to donald
mcneil referring to it on a book
that's my point it's always got to be
about it's always got to be about
context
um but this is why i say the bottom line
should be anyone should be able to say
what they choose to say
that's it and if they say something
that's offensive and and even horrible
then then you you then we have a
decision
to either criticize them back or to
remove ourselves from that situation
that that's
the way it's got to be you know i mean
donald mcneil was allowed to say it
it wasn't like someone came in with a
big set of jaw clamps or something and
was like no you're not allowed to finish
the second syllable of that word
um yeah what we shouldn't stand for is
is then
this this decision that he's a racist
could
because although i'm not familiar with
the case from what you've described it's
someone quoting he's clearly not a
racist
in fact it it was probably an
anti-racist point they offered
so there's some there's some accusations
of other things that he said on the trip
and if they're true that kind of
reframes this but
it doesn't really seem like there's as
much evidence and then you think well it
kind of feels like that's being thrown
in after the fact
it's just it's so likely we have so
little truth we have so
i don't know because i don't know about
the specifics of the case let's let's
take the example of a teacher who is
teaching james baldwin and uses the word
because the word is in the text
right we should not stand for anyone
accusing that person of racism it
doesn't make sense
there's absolutely because we're going
to accuse some of the racism you're
going to have to have more uh you have
to have more evidence than he's just
quoted a text it's not enough
right it's it's it's outrageous in fact
i think he would be um
probably in their election of his duty
as a teacher he didn't if he didn't
quote accurately
all right and often in order to make a a
a a point even
in opposition to racism like i said with
the mark twain example
the book doesn't work without in other
words
a book about racism which is critical of
racism won't work
if there's no depiction of racism in it
is it it's just not gonna work
right and these people have no idea
about art i remember reading um
there was a feminist book called [ __ ]
written
is that funny that's all right just
i love that sentence there was there was
there was a feminist book called khan
yeah back in the 80s i think it was and
the subtitle was
a declaration of independence um and i
read this book at the
or not in the 80s because i was a child
i read it in the 90s um and um
there was a moment in the book where i i
just flinched because it was talking
about how
feminists should go and watch films at
the cinema like thelma and louise
and when there's a rape scene they
should stand up and scream at the screen
shut this down this is disgusting how
did it right in other words
any depiction of rape is an endorsement
of rape and creates rape in society
right and i remember reading that
thinking
no one thinks this is incr extreme
extreme stuff no and i knew a lot of
feminists and none of them would have
gone along with this they'd be like well
that's just stupid that's just
thick because there's a difference
between endorsing rape and depicting it
on screen because actually when you're
depicting on screen more often than not
you want it to look bad because it's a
bad thing it tends to not glorify it
yeah
right quite but now that idea is
mainstream that's the norm you see
something depicted in a film
who was that there was one critic saying
we need to call out david lynch for
his violence against women he's not
violent against women
he's depicted violence against certain
women he's also depicted violence
against a lot of men
probably more but that's not what you
notice is it and and this idea that
artistic representation is the same as
the thing i it blows my mind because
it's someone who is so politicized they
don't understand art
they don't get what art is they don't
get that it's the word art means
artifice
it is a false representation it is not
the actual thing that's what art is
right
you know if you take a scene like the
scene the rape scene in irreversible
which i can't watch to be honest i
watched it once and i
i i would i could never watch it again
it's so brutal so vicious
um it's an extent it's about 10 minutes
scene of
the camera doesn't move and it watches
this rape in an alleyway and it is
unbelievably upsetting
but it's meant to be that's the point
you know
it's not saying look how exciting this
is it's saying look how
[ __ ] horrible this is and that that's
the point and it
it doesn't it doesn't do well actually
to represent
horrible things as though they're okay
and as though they're just
you can just get on with it right it's
not it's not you know
it's it's you know and it's just an
incredible misunderstanding so when i
read that book i remember thinking well
no one's ever going to get on board
without this is and and
i can't believe that that idea has won
out
i can't believe it that now that is that
is the way most
not maybe i'm having my mind skewed
because i just read the guardian all the
time but
a lot of people in power think that now
they think that artistic representation
representation
in film uh needs to send a positive
message
uh it's it it blows my mind you've got
this quote in the book that i really
liked
says history does not look fondly on the
hubris of those who appoint themselves
as arbiters of permissible speech and
thought
their authority is only ever contingent
on the wisdom of their time
would you reckon that future humans are
going to look back on this time and
think
it will be fascinating i think i have
absolutely no doubt that
this this will be a weird uh blip
in human history right i mean i i feel
like i mean i'm living it
and i'm also very aware that of course
we never know
how future generations will perceive but
my god it feels weird enough
being in it with all of the context and
all of the upbringing and all of the
understanding
so you read the article today about how
peop men need to stop wearing ties
because it's a phallic symbol of white
supremacy and you just think well
uh you know that's become normal to me
now i see that sort of thing every day
it shouldn't by the way that should
always be
like what the hell is this kind of
moment who's reading this rubbish
mainstream newspapers guardian again um
and you
we're living it it's everywhere um
i think ultimately in 100 years time or
some people will look
they will they will see it as a pocket
of hysteria this was a moment of
hysteria that that people live
through uh where everyone just started
denying reality
everyone just started saying the aclu
started putting posts out saying
there is no advantage whatsoever to
being born biologically male when it
comes to sport that just simply doesn't
exist
just statements of untruth and they call
them facts do you know what's that i
don't know if you saw that thread
no they call them facts oh the aclu the
the american civil liberties which has
basically become a uh
uh an identitarian activist group now
put out a list of facts
debunked with debunking the myths uh and
one of the myths they debunked was the
idea that um
uh there is any biological difference
between men and women whatsoever that's
a myth that they're just
debunking via twitter so well done
um but you see and i think historians
will look at that and say
okay so there were all these people
saying observable
falsehoods and stating them with such
self-assurance
as though they were fact well religious
zealots in other words
um and um and this was not only did this
happen
but governments and businesses and
corporations and hr departments and the
police
and schools and teachers and
universities
echoed these same falsehoods and
everyone colluded and pretended that
they were real
except for the majority of people who
were standing there saying what what's
going on none of this is real why are
you creating this fantasy land that we
have to
occupy but that's what happened but the
powerful people
sustained the illusion for this length
of time until
suddenly a thing called democracy won
out until the doyle
until the doyle party finally took over
and rose
rose to prominence bearing bearing their
pitchforks and their rocket
grenade launchers idea that i would ever
go into politics i've had a number of
people suggested to me i i
never no no not at all why don't you
start one
no chris williams a party mate i've i've
done far too many party drugs to be able
to ever but in fact actually that might
be what gets me in
maybe that's maybe that is my routine
maybe it's allowed i think it's allowed
these days isn't it because
most of the major politicians have
admitted to uh some sort of drug use
over the past
fair enough so i think yeah i mean i i
couldn't do it because i was a stand-up
comedian
still am i noticing i used past tense
then it's because i've been logged in
pre-covered i used to be a stand-up
comedian
but you well there are no standard
comedians at the moment but if you um
if you know you could go through my old
sets and take a quote out of context
you could do that with any comedian you
know you know and you know what
politicians they get such scrutiny over
absolutely everything they've ever said
but that's not the real reason i
wouldn't do it the real reason i
wouldn't do it is because
i i couldn't do the lying thing i
couldn't
you know if you're part a member of a
party you have to follow the party line
on certain issues and i couldn't be in
that position of not saying what i
thought
i can't do that i'm a terrible liar like
absolutely awful
and many of my ex-girlfriends will
attest to that as well you'll notice i
said x
as well there um what are your thoughts
on trump
being removed from twitter like is that
a freedom of speech issue
so the the question of big tech
censorship i suppose is
um well firstly we have to bring the
argument up to date so when you talk
about how
a lot of people say censorship is just
the the prerogative of the state it's
something the state does that's
a an argument that's completely out of
date about 20 years out of date
uh the big tech companies operate this
oligopoly they
they have um they dominate the
predominant
i mean the predominant public forum the
predominant means of communication they
have more
collective power than any nation state
but they have none of the democratic
accountability that comes with it
um we have to accept that they are in a
unique position
if you're going to say to me um that it
is it is fine for them
to determine the parameters of
acceptable speech uh on
when they not only do they own all of
the major platforms of speech they will
shut down
any competition in its nascent form as
we saw with parliament
so they'll say go and go set up your own
platform someone does they shut it down
right so this is not
you know this is the reason why we have
anti-trust laws we have it for a reason
we
you know when when certain uh uh small
groups of companies dominate a market
there are measures put in place to
address that i don't see why it should
be any different
um with big tech i think the um when it
comes to donald trump specifically
it is terrifies me actually that that uh
these unelected billionaires
can uh decide whether we get to hear
from
an elected president the the leader of
the free world that's a terrifying thing
the last people that should be cheering
on the power of multi-billion dollar
corporations
is anyone who is authentically on the
left because to be on the left
means that you don't support those
people by the way sorry this is sort of
leftism 101
read a book about this stuff it's not
difficult you know it's
it's absolutely nuts that this would be
the case
uh that no leftist thinker going back
beyond 20 because leftism has become
dominated by identity politics now none
of these people are really left-wing
but but go back you know even not even
that long ago and people would have
laughed out loud you went to a socialist
meeting
back in the 80s and said yeah we need
google to i know google didn't exist but
the equivalent
of google to to stand up for our to to
look after us
basically to be our parent do you think
do you think that he would have been
removed if he was
still going to be president for four
years well i always thought they were
going to actually wait until he was out
and i knew they were going to nuke his
account but i thought they were going to
do it like the day after he was out
i think that it just goes to show how
brazen they're becoming
i mean they they now believe that they
they are more powerful than the
president
they believe they're more powerful than
politicians now look it's a
straightforward thing
and you'll always hear that oh well it's
a private company that can do what they
want argument okay well you know that
while that is uh technically true they
absolutely can i suppose they could also
decide
to not allow gay people on their
platform if they want
i think they should face robust
criticism if they decide to do that
and similarly they should face robust
criticism when they are editorializing
on completely partisan lines let's face
it that's exactly
what they are doing so they they do need
to face uh not just criticism there
needs to be
um more than that and i think the way
you do it is they
frankly because they are now behaving
like publishers they should not have
legal protections
that's all it is they if they if they're
going to be publishers then that like
every other publisher like every other
media outlet newspaper
they are responsible for the words that
appear on their platform
end of story because every time twitter
gets sued for a libelous thing that's
there
they say well we're not a publisher
we're a platform we're not responsible
for what we put out
well just just change that change rules
change section 230 of the communications
decency act
and the way you could change it because
obviously you know that act was set up
because of
the proliferation of comment sections on
news sites it can it's it's unreasonable
to expect anyone
to be responsible for everything they
fail to remove in a comment section
that's really unreasonable right
so you need to have those protections so
why not just change that law
uh so that they're not that they're
responsible
so that it doesn't count for illegal
content say so in other words
uh they can't be held responsible for or
libelous libelous or illegal content
uh rather than giving them license as it
currently does the way it's phrased
they have the license to remove anything
that just they just disagree with
that or offends them right no i think as
soon as you're
removing content because you politically
disagree or because it offends your
personal sensibilities as happens
all the time on facebook and twitter
then you are most definitely a publisher
you're editorializing end of story so
i think that's the point at which we
need to have some
some changes to the law you know so by
all means if twitter wants to
say look we're a private company we're
opposed to free speech and we will only
allow
these opinions you can't have these
other opinions which is effectively what
it does anyway now
you know for instance gender critical
feminists are routinely booted off
um because because twitter just doesn't
agree with them right well if you want
that kind of
uh platform then say what you are
just say what you want be honest and
open about it don't pretend that you're
for free speech
which they're not do reckon trump will
run in 2024
i mean i hate predicting the future
because i always get it wrong you can
always get it right
mate every time the only the only thing
that you've ever predicted on the show
that you got wrong
i think was oh no you actually pretty
pretty you said that biden was going to
win as well
yeah so you didn't but i i think
no i'm i i'm happy to predict but i'm no
mother shipton i'm i'm i don't see
andrew
over here look i think
no i wouldn't have thought so i wouldn't
have thought so
i i mean i i could elaborate on that but
i just i just don't i don't i don't
think he's got the necessary support now
uh within the republican party so i just
don't think he would get the nomination
but who knows who knows
my inclination as two englishmen talking
about american politics which this
channel gets
gets criticized for absolutely followers
get really annoyed by this yeah they
hate it i mean
i put a video up with carl benjamin the
youtuber formerly known as sargon of
akad the other day
talking about uh aoc and someone someone
commented and said why youtube brits
always talking about american politics
and i was like well it's because it's
far more interesting than ours like the
closest thing that we have to aoc is
diane abbott
i mean you're very close to the whole
stay in your lane argument there aren't
you
so we're not allowed to take any
interest in world politics that's
ridiculous
and what's the harm you know maybe we
get it wrong that's all right
maybe maybe we get it completely wrong
but in any case
my favorite my favorite thing that i've
heard around this social media freedom
of speech thing is
freedom of speech doesn't mean freedom
of reach
it's like because it rhymes somehow
it's yet somehow it's got more veracity
to it
yeah it's either rhyming or repeating
repetition's the other one have you seen
the the
un women the um women account keeps
putting out these
tweets that are just what was the one
they did the other day there is there is
no wrong way to be a woman
there is no wrong way to be a woman
there were eight times it's like well i
wasn't convinced by the third time
but i was being persuaded and then by
the eighth i'm like oh yeah
man you've nailed it you know if
persuasive rhetorical
documents from the history all they were
were just repeating the same sentence
over and over again until they wore you
down into submission
i mean that's jack nicholson in the
shining that's not a serious argument
that's all work and no play makes jack a
dull boy you know it's it's insane
it's the clap emojis isn't it if you put
the clap emojis between
each of the words that's i love that
that's hard
all the all the full stop after every
word
see you know it's very very very simple
yeah
one one thing that's interesting that
can never go on sorry
one thing that's interesting i was just
going to say we are on we're on some
hell of a time delay i think here
between me and you
it's not an issue at the moment because
no one can leave the house
but why shouldn't people protest against
speakers that they don't like
uh they should i don't have a problem
with that
why shouldn't they petition to get them
removed from the university
or the campus or the wherever
the problem i haven't i haven't got a
problem with protest at all i think i
think uh
protest is a sign of a healthy democracy
you should be able to protest whatever
you like
my problem is people capitulating to
protests that are clearly asinine
right so if if i for instance say i
don't
want this speaker on campus because he
eats meat and i'm a vegetarian
and it will therefore normalize the
killing of pigs
right if i say something as ludicrous as
that i would expect the university
authorities to say
okay you're you're free to have that
opinion but shut up now cause we're not
gonna listen we're not interested
uh but you know go and have your protest
whatever um
but it's the demand it's it's the it's
the threats
it's when protests uh literally prevent
people from speaking as in they sound
fire alarms or they prevent
the event going ahead or they threaten
and therefore the cost of security
become prohibitive these are these are
that's where you are
preventing someone else from speaking
and that's the distinction i don't
have a problem with anyone protesting at
all i think
i think the sort of protest i had in
mind was when was it steve bannon went
to
oxford to speak and there was
essentially like a human wall
of people in front of the entrance
that's like like
like i said the distinction is clear uh
peaceful protest i'm all for
any form of protest that turns violent i
oppose no matter who is doing it and for
what reason
and any uh measures that prevent other
people from making their own informed
choice right so if you if in other words
because what you're doing is if you
form a wall to prevent people actually
to prevent the event taking place
you are acting in loco parentas you were
deciding on behalf of your peers what
they can and cannot hear
that's not for you to do what's local so
i oppose that
in local parents in place of a parent
it's a ponzi way of saying that
um but it's um but basically
you know that's what i that i think is
that's when you are threatening free
speech you are
you know and that's when you are acting
like an authoritarian because what
you're saying is my
particular view of the world is the only
one that matters and that's the opposite
of of uh
of a liberal democracy and what it
stands for i've got my favorite
passage from the book uh and i'm going
to read it out here
in an age when lived experience is often
valued more than objective truth the
core tenets of liberalism due process
and free speech are bound to be at risk
lived experience is what we used to call
anecdotal evidence
a fallacious form of reasoning that has
misled many into believing that ours is
an essentially oppressive society
overrun by fascists and undergirded by
white supremacy
needless to say those who whose lived
experience
tell them that this worldview bears
little resemblance to reality
are quickly discounted it would seem
that lived experience only matters
if it is of the approved sort good
good words andrew oh thank you thank you
chris
um because that is something that
troubles me and it's something i've
already gone into with you before about
about
uh uh you know firstly the inherent
contradictions of the movement
so if you're going to say that objective
truth doesn't matter and all that
matters is people's lived experience and
perception in other words
um then you're gonna have to take on
board everyone's perception aren't you
or what you're really doing is you're
saying that uh no what i meant was
people whose perception agrees with mine
and then it's a different thing isn't it
so there's
the inherent contradiction within it but
also the idea that we can just discount
objective truth well
you know it's it's it's it's so opposed
to
basic enlightenment values of reason and
scientific inquiry it's
it's it's absolutely nuts i mean yeah
there are people who will say that
homeopathy
objectively works because i had some of
that course
and i got better but you see that we
don't make these sweeping statements on
the basis of that
do we because that's not a sufficient
study that it worked for you
right that's not that's not that's not
sufficient is it um
what was the darren brown show where he
did the uh the horse racing the system
have you seen that one no you should
watch it there's an hour-long show
called the system where he basically
uh he shows you uh this process by which
he
he he picks a member of the public and
he feeds them the information which
horse is going to win a race
and he does it five or six times and it
works every time impossible right
and then he shows you how he did it and
i won't tell you how he did it but it's
a similar
it's a similar thing because all we're
seeing is her experience of winning
every time
and we're not seeing what's actually
happening which is a much bigger picture
that you might even be able to guess
from what i've just said um
because we cannot honestly watch it it's
great um we cannot
we cannot base our perception our
conclusions about reality
on our experience of reality okay
because if we do that
chaos reigns as the fox said in
antichrist
you know we we sorry that's a bit of a
niche reference i just love that film
you've seen the film antichrist
yeah it's the last one trevor you know
the bit where the fox speaks
it says chaos reigns it's so chilling i
love it anyway um
where was i sorry i'm getting you just i
love every time that you're on for some
reason we seem to have like really
apocalyptic
references i think our first ever
introduced you was like twitter cracking
and crumbling beneath your feet as you
as we started the episode it's always so
apocalyptic
under um under a biden administration
do you think that it's better or worse
for free speech what's your predictions
there or what's your what's your sense i
know that you don't like making
predictions
i think it's worse i think it is worse
so this is the uh
i mean trump had his blind spots on free
speech which we should never be he was
not
very good on press freedom for instance
i think if he if he could have had his
way he would have
quite been quite happy to shut down his
critics and muzzle his critics i don't
think there could be any doubt about
that
i think the risk with biden is that he
you know i mean i remember having a lot
of discussions before the election and
a lot of people who were voting by them
were sort of saying but you know these
fears that he's going to be
a woke person he was voted in because
he's the non-woke
candidate right that's why we don't have
we don't have elizabeth warren
in the white house because wokeness
doesn't win votes let's face it you know
uh this is why kamala harris had to drop
out the primaries so early because she
just wasn't popular um and so
you know all and then and then a lot of
people say to me you know well that
it's a it's a false fear but then within
two days
a number of the executive orders are
specifically woke executive orders and
you think oh hang on a minute this is a
bad thing
wokeness and and the opposition of
freedom of speech go hand in hand
they just do because because as i've
said of this belief in
the power of language to to form reality
and that's really what it's about
uh so i don't think firstly also i don't
think biden and his administration
have any appetite to address the
problems of big tech censorship
because big tech is on their side at the
moment
you know it's very myopic because if you
go into the
you know they should be thinking long
term here um they don't want to set
these kind of precedence
so there's that uh there's also a
movement as you know in america to have
the the the first amendment
changed amend the amendment so that um
hate speech
is not protected speech uh but of course
hate speech as a formulation
is just as i say in the book it's a kind
of fudge uh
for to to deal with uh or to suggest
that speech that you don't like
is not subject to constitutional
protection that's all that that is so um
which is why i argue in the book was to
be one of the the arguments i imagine is
going to get me in a bit of trouble is
that i think all hate speech laws ought
to be repealed
and that there is no place for hate
speech laws on any statute books in a
liberal democracy
um and i think uh under biden and his
administration the problem of hate
speech is going to get worse
as it seems to be in this country a
little bit you've got the law commission
pushing
pushing now for further hate speech
regulation when what they should be
doing is dialing
existing legislation back and they're
going the other way the smp
of course in scotland under humza yusuf
the justice secretary
as far as i can see is a kind of maniac
who thinks that you should um
uh prosecute people in their own homes
for things that they say
i mean this is properly authoritarian
stuff like even a lot of people on the
left are like oh
hang on a minute this is too much you
know this is uh
it's it's it's scary stuff and um
the problem is we need to i would talk
to a politician about this
the other day we need to find a way for
politicians to be brave enough
just to stand up and say because it
sounds like you're saying i want
everyone to be able to be hateful i want
everyone to say hateful things
and you're not saying that you're
talking about a much bigger picture
about free speech
and about the fact that the state has no
place at deciding what its citizens can
and cannot say
because that way tyranny lies so it's
going to take a brave politician it's
always
it always takes a degree of courage to
defend free speech because what you're
doing is you're
defending the rights of unpleasant
people to say unpleasant things as
as a corollary of what you're doing
inevitably because speech that isn't
controversial doesn't require protection
so it's difficult um and that's why i
emphasize in the book that if you're
defending someone who's saying something
that's utterly reprehensible
you should also make the point just
strategically just make the point
that you don't agree with what they're
saying and you find it reprehensible be
clear
because otherwise people will use it
against you they'll do it anyway by the
way you know i mean like it doesn't
matter what you say because people just
put words into your mouth that seems to
be the norm now people just
decide what you secretly think you know
you saw this god
owen jones tweeted the other day that he
was saying that the reason why gb news
is so popular
can be explained because everyone who
supports it has this fear
of of uh is a reactionary who has a fear
of progress
so what you've done is you've just
decided what's going on in the minds of
all these millions of people about a
program that doesn't even exist yet
that you've also just decided what it's
about it's this insane
degree of entitlement i think it's i
think it's demented
i mean the idea that you you you think
you know what's going on in anyone's
heads
is is is is you know on the face of it
absurd
but to just casually diagnose millions
of people with your cod psychology
over twitter i can't imagine being that
entitled
that narcissistic for god's sake you
know just before i'd sent tweet i'd be
like
i'd be thinking oh should i should i say
should i be advertising the fact that i
think
i'm better than everyone else and can
decide on their behalf what they're
secretly thinking should i tweet that
or should i have a little bit of [ __ ]
humility well
not everyone has that the thing that i
can't
get out of my head is i i don't meet
people like
owen jones or anybody else i don't meet
a decorating head i don't meet these
sorts of people that say these sorts of
things despite having met an awful lot
of people but newcastle seems to
filter out the maniacs in in quite a
good way no one wants to come this far
yeah i think
i don't know what it is you have your
own kind of maniacs though that's
correct yeah that is very true
um and the thing i always think i always
excuse it away in my own head
by saying it's just the clout because
now
things that are sort of inflammatory and
cause response
they garner momentum and
that this i know that that can't be true
i mean that's the best
faith like potential that their words
can have
is that they're just using them and they
don't believe them because if they
believe them this is a whole
new magnitude of ridiculous foolishness
what you're doing there is you're trying
to make sense of the inexplicable and
that that's an understandable instinct a
normal pursuit right
it is noble and you're also giving them
the benefit of the doubt weirdly
by suggesting that they're maybe being
disingenuous you're saying they can't be
as
maniacal as they seem uh so that's
actually quite a positive thing that
you're doing there
but unfortunately i you know i on the
other hand do like to take people at
face value and i and i
i i believe that people mean what they
say
unless proven otherwise so i'm going to
assume
that they they do believe this and that
is a scarier world you're in there i
mean that is that is
that is a frightening place although i
do notice that
in conversation such people rarely say
things that are that
unhinged they they tend to reserve them
for
for twitter or you know so i don't know
what that tells us
um uh but i you know i hope you're right
i hope i hope it is just a game uh and
that they don't seriously believe what
they say
i hope so too free speech and why it
matters will be linked in the show notes
below
have you got anything else is there
anything else happening in the world of
andrew doyle at the moment well just i'm
you know
because it's locked down i go for walks
every day through fields and um
you know i don't know how to use
instagram i don't know if i've said this
i don't know how to use it
so i just post pictures of what i see on
my walks and they're normally sheep
and it occurred to me the other day that
i think people think i've got a fetish
because i just post pictures of sheep on
instagram
and it's not so if anyone does follow me
on instagram that's not the reason it's
just that
i don't know how to use it i don't know
how to reply or do anything on instagram
and if i'm out in a field and there's a
sheep
i'll take a picture of the sheep because
i quite like sheep um so don't get the
wrong idea
if that's all i'd say cool so new book
new book out
and a caveat around the sort of images
that people can expect to see
on your instagram those are the two main
announcements that we've got
well i'm not doing anything else because
i'm stuck at home so i'm only writing
or walking and there is nothing else to
do so uh i wish i had more exciting
exciting news that to me is a wonderful
way to finish an episode
andrew it's always a pleasure to have
you on mate i hope that we get to see
each other again
properly at some point but for now we'll
continue doing this over the internet
thanks chris
[Music]